[Music]
boy snow man y know what it is Mr
September 20ing right here with
bootc.com what I said let's get it hey
ladies and gentlem man the city about to
be on fire tonight I got one of the ill
MC to ever do it  right in front of me
man
J's what's good Big
Show headl in the PAL come
man up yeah so you been doing the tour
man uh TM 103 finally coming out nextth
September 20 going down man the wa is
over yall know what it is yall know how
I come correct every time you know what
I mean it's crazy yeah it's crazy man
it's crazy I wish we can get into it
right now all of I i I have to ask you
about one song I heard about uh if I'm
right if I  'm wrongrect me on the MC on
the song but is Andre Drake and j-z it's
possible possible it's possiblez I heard
anything possible okay SN that be
[Music]
St thatd be crazy uh what else can you
tell us about the album I mean you know
the album is crazy man you know what I'm
saying it um like I said I went in man I
just i just locked in man got studio for
like a mon half knocked out the album
knocked out the real back mix tape m in
a couple  days the real back two is
coming yeah real soon done just wpped it
up you know what I mean fact I wpped it
up last night in your hometown oh in
Phoenix studio straight straight off the
stage oh that's what it is straight to
the studio room and  got it done when's
the mix dropping i mean we drop it now
want to oh man we define do the first win
is my anthem right yeah we been going
back and for don't try tell he said that
flexing is better than wi I don'  t knowo
when when is that Stadium music come on
Flex flexing is my joint though flexing
is my joint yeah um so uh shake life is
that the official first single from TM
103 it's one of them you know what I'm
saying like real talk man  you know i do
what I do because I love it you know
what I'm saying I do what I do for the
people who ride for me cuuse i ride for
them so I really don't use the
terminology single you know what I'  m
saying i'm just going put i'm putting
records man know you get caught up in
the single thing you know you might be
some I got you now we about 24 days
comes out
yeah can you can you let us I mean I
know  I kind of asked you about one song
can you can you let lose any official
features on the album i mean I wouldn't
tell you features but you know I want to
keep the B you know what I mean cuz I
didn't do too  many but I did the right
ones but I will tell you this I mean for
for four this got to be the you know one
of the best attempts you know what I'm
saying if not the best you know I mean
when I got in I  listened to this matter
of fact I listen to a couple songs when
I was in the studio last night and I was
tripping cuz I a't heard in a while and
man it this t 103 hust ambition fact I'm
let you call me and  meass going for on
this for baby I'm like Floyd Mayweather
around this thing yeah un there it is
man my de in theild hey what is your
favorite uh personally i'm sure the
first St motivation you know has to
always you know mean something  more than
the other ones what's your favorite
personal album musically though out of
your three out I mean it was the
recession until this the recession is is
my favorite a lot of cats didn't know
man you know I really educated myself
circul yeah no SH  i really educated
myself to get that album done man you
put all my jury my cars up you know what
I mean went back home and just kicked it
man I was just you know living regular
you know what I mean like for real for
real though cuz  because I wanted to get
into St of mind man because it was a bad
time and I nobody want to hear about my
you know I mean but you know I watch the
news up on it yeah there it is it's the
best one though by the
way
103 September 20 watch what I tell you
now you always have like you always have
like a I would say like real Hipop like
boom record like crazy like circul on
your album do have anything like that
for all the hiop M I to have nothing
that's crazy you  know what I'm saying
shake life is one of those joints and I
got this joint finishing now it's called
legendary it's crazy you know what I
mean but other than that man I really
just did I did what you do when you're
on your  fourthbum in the streets love
you and the industry doubt you you got
to show again good at that by the way
yeah hey yo the takeover about to po off
man we come back with to freddys man
where where's Gary ind be walking
through the door in a  minute now I
wanted to ask you man of course you got
um you got new uh you know you've had
cte Entertainment you put out you know
what I'm saying you put out the uh the
ctebum USDA compilation um you just
signed gangster Gibs  Freddy Gibs yeah
man um what made you sign Freddy Gibbs I
know he's been making a lot of a lot of
noise i mean he's i mean you know Gibs
is one of them type of cats man he
already had Hustler man you know what
I'm  saying he just he just needed a plug
you know what I mean and that was the
plug i definitely understand everything
he represents everything he do and you
know Gary love him you know what I'm
saying and and the world need to hit
this you guys  you guys are two of the
most authentic yeah you know what I
don't think they want it with us
together man me and him don't play on
the same track it's like it's like
basketball that strip Stripes is it's
like Kobe Kobe i mean  it's like Kobe and
LeBron being on the same team you know I
mean r DMC is my joint yeah fact on the
real back too me and Gibs got like maybe
like six joints there just me and him is
he on TM 103 of course I wouldn't  t have
no other way that's what I'm talking
no other way now I wanted to ask you the
last I had DJ up here we're talking
about the money record you did with
withud and he was saying that you I'd
asked him  you know cuz he's with you
know he r with Ross lot and he said you
guys had squash whatever qus you all had
is that the case cuuse I later that that
might not have been true is everything I
spoke to in a while but when I speak
to say that we say that I think that
that speaks Val that's fair right
that is fair when it comes to like the
last year and a half or so you know a
lot of people kind of being naysers when
it comes to the Pro finally coming  out
it Kep getting pushed back it seem like
a lot of people you know can't get his
album Out um what what was the cause of
the delay and what do you have to say to
the people who you knowed that you I
say this you  know I mean it's a lot of
politics in the game you know what I'm
saying for one you know mean that's one
side of it and uh two is type of cats
you know me I have to go off what I live
by and uh for  a while I was on the road
you know I'm saying I was touring with j
you know what I'm saying The Blueprint 3
tour me and Wayne did the um the Most
Wanted tour and I I went in my roots so
I went in recorded  mod so when I got
back home you know I had to readjust you
know what I mean and that's what I did
you know plus i had a lot of checks I
had to go cash you know what I'm saying
I had to go you know  kick it with my son
do my daddy thing but after that it was
back to the studio every grinding what
people got to understand is you know I
ain't the type of cat that's about to
put out just to get no money or a check
cuz  I never done it for the money if it
ain't classic material I don't want to
be involved with it so I just got back
and got it right you know what I mean I
know you got some best bestselling
authors that take that little  hiatus
then they come back and smash you know
what I mean movie directors Go like that
yes it is that's what I'm talking direct
avatar how manyon what was the last one
he did
Titanic he came back and that's what we
TM 101 was the Titanic  t 103 is avatar
all
right